there are some new faces for Calvin
Klein and they may look very familiar to
you
Mike tattoo it's just be grateful it
wasn't for the looks it wasn't cuz I
wanted a tattoo wasn't any of that was
just to have a permanent reminder on me
Crossley Gerber just might be fashions
newest male supermodel the 17 year olds
definitely got what it takes the looks
check the family pedigree check
he's just nabbed his first big campaign
and it's for Calvin Klein wait I had to
find successes I don't know I saw quo
that was really funny it was said work
until you've no longer have to introduce
yourself and that was a good kind of
guideline for me my cousin
beaver was in his 20s when he plugged
the brand night since Presley's still a
minor
we don't see him in his skivvies
following in his parents footsteps
his mom is supermodel Cindy Crawford and
his dad Randy was also a model before
becoming a restaurant mogul the new
campaign also features Margot Robbie the
iconic Kate Moss zoe kravitz who shows
she's got pipes like her rocker dad
Lenny and Bella Hadid younger says to
fellow model Gigi like Presley and Joey
Bella fits the young rich and famous
profile her mom Yolanda is one of the
real housewives of beverly hills and her
dad is a multi-millionaire real estate
developer
seems like this 19 year olds got some
pretty lofty ambitions too I think
changing the world is actually one of my
biggest goals in life but I'm only 19 I
need to figure out what I want to change
but I will change the world